- But this all kind of started out,
I didn't know this about
you, so you went to Julliard.
- Yeah.
- But you went on scholarship
that Robin Williams paid for.
- I know.
What an incredible
human being that guy is.
- Like I didn't know that and.
- Yeah so.
- Did you meet him?
- I sadly did not.
So you know the scholarship
was a huge deal.
I'm the first person in my
family to go to college.
It paid for all of my schooling.
It paid for me to be able
to go home for Christmas
and see my family, all my
books, my apartment, everything.
- Yeah.
- And so every year I wrote a letter to
you know, thank him, but
I never got to meet him
and I was in LA, I had like a meeting with
a independent film
director at like Fred Segel
or something in the cafe
and I told him the story
and all of a sudden
Robin Williams walks in
to the restaurant area
and I was like, oh my gosh.
And he goes, You have to go say hi.
And I was like, okay, okay.
And then I thought, you know what,
I'm gonna let him enjoy his
meal first, I don't wanna
rush over there.
- Oh, that's polite.
- Yeah, but then in
the middle of the meal,
he jumped up and ran out.
So I jumped up like I was gonna chase him
and then I thought, no,
I don't wanna scare him
and I didn't go up to him
and I always regret that
because I never then had
- Oh no.
- the opportunity to meet him.
And I say to people, anytime
someone comes up to me,
I'm always like, thank you for coming up,
because this happened to me once
where I had an opportunity to meet someone
that I really wanted to talk
to and I didn't take it.
So now whenever someone comes up to me
I'm so happy to say hi to them.
- Yeah.
Well and especially like, he
probably would've loved that
that he, to see like where his money went,
you know, that's cool.
- After I tackled him.
- You had a reason
like to go up, you know,
you weren't just like the
rest of us and had no reason,
like, we're just fans.
Like, you know, you had
like a really solid reason.
I'm sorry you didn't get that,
but it's a really good lesson though.
It is, it's a great lesson.
- For all of us to like really
take advantage of the moment.